with an average salary of 150 000 in the
United States data scientists has become
one of the most in-demand jobs of 2023.
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics data scientist employment is
expected to increase by 11 between 2019
and 2029 with 11.5 million job openings
by 2026 at an annual growth rate of 28
percent
companies like meta Amazon Google and
PWC are recognizing the values of data
and are hiring data scientists with
salaries going as high as two thirty
seven thousand dollars which makes data
science one of the most in-demand jobs a
survey held by PWC says that 9 out of 10
offer Learners achieve their learning
objectives after a successful course
completion so are you ready to take your
career to the next level simply learns
data science master program in
collaboration with IBM ranked as the
number one data science course by career
Karma will teach you all the skills you
need to become a data scientist expert
and land your dream job this master
programs cover python food data science
where we will cover basics of python
working with data in Python working with
numpy arrays Etc next up we have applied
data science with python in this course
we will get an introduction to data
science data wrangling Etc next course
covered in Masters program is machine
learning where we will learn the various
ml algorithms like the season trees
random Forest unsupervised Learning Time
series modeling Etc now coming to the
course 4 which is Tableau training in
this course we will learn working with
metadata filters in Tableau Advanced
video analytics Etc and the final one is
data science Capstone in this course we
will learn data preprocessing techniques
model building and fine tuning
leveraging various techniques and much
more along with this there are many more
topics and Concepts like SQL training
deep learning with Keras and tensorflow
Etc that will be covered in this data
science Masters program so what else can
you expect from this program this
program include exclusive hackathons
master classes and ask me anything
sessions by ibil this also includes
webinars from industry experts 25 plus
industry relevant projects from likes of
Amazon Walmart Mercedes-Benz and many
more it also includes 24 7 learning
Support also after successful completion
of these data science courses you will
be eligible to apply for the job assist
program where you will get the benefits
of IIM jobs Pro membership for six
months the zoomi building assistance
Career Mentoring and interview
preparation sections via webinars and
Career Fairs the online training will
give you hands-on experience with
Technologies like R python machine
learning Tableau Hadoop and Spark Etc
you'll also get hands-on experience with
the latest tools and Technologies
including numpy tensorflow pandas and
many more this data science master
program course in collaboration with IBM
this joint partnership between simply
learn and IBM introduces students to an
integrated Blended learning approach
making them experts in the data science
field upon completion of this data
science course you will receive IBM
certification for the IBM courses and
simply loan certification for all the
courses in the learning path
these certificates will testify your
skills and justify your data science
knowledge simply learn also offers
financial aid in terms of VMI so what
are you waiting for don't miss out on
the chance to take your career to the
next level enroll in a data science
master program course today and start
your journey to become a data science
expert the link is added in the
description box and the comment section
below